hello everyone welcome to House of
Juarez I'm sorry I'm Jeff and today
we're playing a Brazilian yeah yeah we
shall be interesting
yeah it's called um in Saudi Dodge is
all right somehow I think I realized
Portuguese I did listen to the
pronunciation on the Internet ah what it
is it's the Portuguese for the English
word insanity and the whole things in
Portuguese I assume this is setting up
the story
as mentioned before we don't speak
Portuguese this game is actually
inspired by cryosphere
and I believe it has the same producer
oh really yes super interesting I guess
that means inta oh oh that's what she
means I like that we can apply a video
game how to UM games and languages that
we don't it oh my god dude so he's the
nice thing there so much accomplishment
things by being able to do simple things
why is it like Flickr yeah it's very
easy um you can see just above my head
it's actually a picture of the key
that's flickering okay so someone just
translated the sign outside actually
says oh my gosh thank you sanatorium
refuge of angels oh I don't want to be
in a sanatorium that's a scary place
this is actually how the guy walks I
don't know maybe he's drunk or something
vodka given his gracious the flickering
is not a glitch that's how the game
works
oh no now we in the sanatorium being in
the sanatorium yeah the black ball
flashing is supposed to be happening
check messages this woman takes someone
help I need to get out I hope we have a
nice background like Yvonne Strahovski
or something oh it's not Yvonne but oh
he turned so slowly the sensitivity in
this game is why I keep hearing
something I know is it singing cuz
that's what I'm hearing sounds like
wailing whoa what what I just had it
yeah okay I like my future a play games
where she doesn't have a gun it might
just be a jump scare he might no come
back or he might come back hey [ __ ] I
have to move my mouse like oh my god
dude that's look terrifying yeah what
does that mean no trying can do no
jagged sorry new industry but I had the
door burst open it means locked Oh
shrinking lock thank you oh you're
really skinny yeah
Oh gross let's just run E and it looks
safe alright yeah sure what do you
no way jeans on mine I got the kinder
drink it's like hey I'm super faucet
yep oh that looks nice
um I definitely did you see the guy in
the hallway just walk through I did and
loosely and - arms out of the ceilings
that guy to get us I don't want the
hands together I want to be gone by
anything in general stop looking at it
wait a back
that's mmm [ __ ] terrifying
so I've decided to read to find the
Portuguese word for locked to refer to
serene and I Manning up and playing
through this to it terrifying
please would be offended by my boss at
ization uh just keep run run I think
just go straight I would just run i I
think scream means run good something
between is way up he's as slow as I am
so when I read about this game um on
this site it was like the first line was
I'm still getting Ava in Sonny dodge it
was like this game he's like stuck read
this article like this still trying to
like recover which terrifies
oh okay all right everyone three two run
okay you can do this I believe in you so
much oh I do believe in either I believe
in neither yes I too hate mannequins
they have a special place really in my
heart I don't like um like you know the
craving mana dude I really want to he
could with that round at us I don't know
if he will yep that's where I go looks
good to me
oh geez hey this new game ah spooky what
spooky scary cuz we don't know anything
about it we don't understand what's
going on are you finishing my sentence
yep
oh this game is a nightmare
I did not expect this I can do now a man
who buggering he'll cry sickles okay
let's just go left
yep oh he's okay he's slow like like a
snail like a very oh that guy oh dude
look at his hands yeah scary oh it's a
tank can somebody read that if you can
maybe that'll be great and I think you
will be good nope no I don't want going
bad doc it is
no I don't want to go it looks like
something said you go out don't say
where you're going how many days more do
you intend to disappear that's what the
text said do that ass is terrifying dude
please don't please
careful stop thief just keep on oh he
looks at the tags like gotta check my
messages it's like a teenage girl he's
dead well can I take that from her
um I feel like that's not a good thing
cuz what killed him just just just turn
if something killed him I don't want to
meet that thing no he hung himself
he's on a noose [ __ ]
this fire does not be oh yeah I know I
see it I see it okay
he's just a little bit upset seriously
screw this darkness man I know didn't
this doc remind ah this chairs are on
the ceiling the chairs are on the
[ __ ] ceiling I think we need to walk
into the doctor and if there's someone
in there that's trying to kill us
let's just leave no actually I don't
wanna go in there I don't want to go in
either but I think we have to oh this is
nothing
oh I think it's so good a key okay
the upset guy the upset guy he seems
pretty upset dude Jesus
um listen I'll go straight I'm walking
as fast as I can
the jumpin light it's snow I don't know
this game is giving us too much hell I
have to walk past it again there's
another one just keep right hook right
hook right hook right hook right okay
okay oh my gos another one on the left
there hug laughs hug laughs Holly no
it's coming it's coming left okay they
all seem to be left-handed if that helps
you okay all right it's not actually
less creepy that's Christ that was close
that was me walking into the chair why
does I like that Mariner it was
intentional an intensive tusk that's
James loudest chit keypad yeah okay exam
you think you're so tough
please don't move oh here we have we
have movie the number of corners every
time I've seen shape puzzles before it's
been corners or edges there's no zero
one go one like for the edge yes
did we get it I don't Jessica just don't
render yes disk and render
should you look at the science to people
can so obviously the first one was
assassin I seem I think people will
translate as we carry spot it murderer
is the next ones murderer demon the next
one was Damon mmm-hmm why you guys are
so cool thank you
guys is so cool I'm so impressed he
looks pretty dead just a mannequin hi
can you tell
he'll get up just go try it try it again
try it again
Oh hold it up like quiet panic while
we're both like now I was looking at a
middle of the room they want to get
handsy huh
bear little and wait they just want to
give us a hand
this is where we started this outside
again all the cars on did I leave your
mommy
let's just getting it right sorry doles
on the other side okay maybe Brazilians
drive on the sunny Australians do okay I
have a theory the game is actually still
going
no I suppose to just drive away
someone's coughing nurse on crying of
course I go in there hmm that sounds
like I said I should move to what yeah
oh hey buddy what does that would mean I
really wish this is the room we heard up
in you that's off is that us you you you
okay maybe you guys can read any of that
if you anyone Kiowa suggests applaudin
does it okay we were always in the cell
the guy killed his own wife oh that was
the woman who was crying yes I killed my
wife I was found hugging her body but
that was crazy awesome and this is gonna
be a really long highlights real right
if you're watching it but that game is
really great yes
that was insanity - yes and that
basically translates to insanity
it is a Brazilian developed game so it
isn't bazillion reported years yeah why
can people pick it up if you look for if
you google it online actually it's
hosted off the developer sort of a media
file uploaded thing yes thank you very
much for joining us yeah as always leave
us your comments you can tweet us with
the hashtag HOH live or there's comments
both on YouTube and GameSpot we'll take
suggestions of what you want to see us
play yes we'll be back again let me know
what you want to see me play next week
and I will see you again soon bye
everyone